world leaders are sharing mixed
reactions to president Trump's attack on
globalism during his United Nations
address the president highlighted his
america-first policies during
yesterday's speech saying the future
belongs to Patriots New Zealand's Prime
Minister Jacinto Dern is among the
leaders in New York for the UN General
Assembly her countries you know got
global attention for implementing strict
gun control measures after the mass
shootings in Christchurch back in March
earlier this morning we spoke to her in
an exclusive interview about her
closed-door meeting with President Trump
this week and what he thinks of New
Zealand's gun laws word is that our
president did expressed interest in the
measures that you implemented what can
you share with us about that meeting
oh there have been those who've been
interested in what and what happened in
New Zealand obviously after the 15th of
March where 51 lives were lost from our
Muslim community the sentiment was
really clear we we are a country who has
legitimate use for guns our farming
community particularly for peace control
and animal welfare issues but there was
a really a real line in the same moment
for us as a nation and a question was
asked you know why why do we need why
does anyone need military-style
semi-automatic weapons or assault rifles
and so that's where we drew the line
within 10 days we announced that those
laws would change within a month roughly
it was done and now we're in the middle
of buying back all of those weapons and
we've had 20,000 of them returned in
over 70,000 parts did you get the
impression he wants to do that here I
got the impression he was interested I
would be sticking guessing anything
beyond that when ideas like buybacks and
gun bans come up in this country one of
the criticisms and I know you've heard
it in your country as well is look law
abiding people are gonna give you the
guns back but they're the criminals and
the potential terrorists of people you
don't want to have these weapons it's
not like they're gonna listen to the
band well I mean one of the one of the
points that we try to make of course is
if there's only a very small proportion
of people who are licensed if a commit
crime a small portion but if the guns
are not stored properly cared for
properly they are the ones that can
still in turn to the black market
there is a connection there are you
punishing law-abiding citizens while
letting the criminals continue with
their criminal activity no I mean
certainly the perspective we've had from
those who have been part of the buyback
as they see this as the right thing to
do and in Australia you know they did
see results off the back of their
buyback scheme and so I look to them and
see that that was a positive experience
for them and for us
actually there is just no rational
reason to have these in circulation we
didn't even know how many we had but in
fact we've had 20,000 returned for a
small country of less than 5 million
people that's a big result for us
sometimes our president has been
criticised for what we what is seen as
divisive rhetoric in this country how do
you think it's viewed on the
international stage increasingly I think
and I'd make this statement about any of
us you know even if you're from a
smaller country like New Zealand you you
you can be shot onto a platform
depending on on what's happening in your
corner of the world the point I've tried
to make is that increasingly we're
actually all amplified within each
other's borders so nothing that we say
within our own countries anymore is just
limited to that we will hear each other
now and our peoples feel the effect of
that and I don't say that to point to
any one leader actually that's a duty of
care that we all have and in this
borderless worlds now I think we need to
be mindful that other countries here
kids hear it and and I would say have
impact only 23 of the 193 UN member
states have female leadership why do you
think the number is so low then what do
you think are there consequences when
you don't have more female leaders I'm
particularly inclined to try and create
and there's really speeds or this click
you know and I think these lots of
reasons you know I reflect back in my
own region we're doing what we can to to
lift the pipeline ultimately if you're
going to have female leaders you need
female members of parliament and female
politicians it's not a particularly
enticing place to be and so I I say my
starting point is how can we make
politics
like a place where you can make a
positive contribution and so that's part
of my philosophy is to tell the stories
of why and how we can do good but to
Gail's question before what do you think
the consequences for the entire world
are when we have so few women leaders
well I think they wouldn't want to make
an assumption that just because you're a
female that you'll produce particular
political outcomes or policies everyone
comes from their own perspectives you
know and I don't mean to draw too many
assumptions but there will be times when
we'll might choose to do things
differently and you're always everyone
brings their personal experience to the
table and so particularly you know I
think if you come as a as a mother as a
carer it will influence the way you look
at the world in issues one of the most
talked about probably the most talked
about moment at the UN this week has
been the speech by credit to Newberg a
16 year old challenging the leaders of
the world she should you think she made
an impact yes I do do you think the
world leaders heard her well I certainly
did and I'd like to think that we had
heard her some time ago but it was
whether or not everyone that need to
hear at any given time we're all in the
room we need to hear that generation and
and they don't want speeches they do
want to know that we're taking it
seriously yes we are to see more of our
interview with Prime Minister just send
Oder and visit our website at CBS this
morning calm